FOSTERSS
KNOCKED OUT.
TOKARSKI HANGS ON TO THAT KANE .
AND JOHNSON GETS FED
RIGHT HERE!
COMES ICE
AGAIN.
SHOT ON REBOUND AND THERE.
THE REBOUND KOMGCOMES OUTSA ALO
.
A SHOT KNOCKED OUT IN FRONT.
AND THE HAWKS.
RIGHT IN VLASIC.
CLEARED IT OUT IN FRONT,
SOMEBODY WAS GOING TO MAKE
MITTELSTADT GETS AWAY.
BATTED OUT IN CENTER. BACK IN A.
AND FREE.
BROUGHT IN TO THE LINE.
NOW CLEARED.
BACK I
TAGE THOMPSON, THERE HE IS.
THAT BABY IS HOME ANDIT, HE'S L
ICE.
HE SPINS
IT AWAY AS PASS. ON A  THE SHOT!
REDIRECTION BY STROME.
YOU WATCH THIS.
HE SEES H H
AND HIGH IN THE AIR.
IT'S A BREAK FOR THE ONES FOR
TOKARSKI, WHO PUTS OON CHASED B.
WORKED IT BACK INTO THE CORNER.
CHICAGO K K LET THE SHOT  POWERD
GOAL OF THE YEAR.
THIS IN HIS EIGHTH TRYING TO IT
AND CASEY MITTELSTADT HAMMERS IT